this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer you've seen the classic 1932
Boris Karloff version doesn't ring a
bell
okay you explore Tom Cruise's dark
universe let's give that one to well
then it's time to revisit the only mummy
film anyone under 80 has actually seen
and enjoyed the mummy the Brendan Fraser
one meet Rick O'Connell whose solution
to every problem is to shoot guns at it
literally every problem he may not have
a plan who was talking about more he may
not have consent but Rick's armed with
the ultimate superpower being Brendan
Fraser I mean look at those eyes that
jawline who wouldn't want to be phrase
raiding their doom huh I am going to
kiss you
mr. Arcana joining O'Connell for the
ride is a crude Arab stereotype ands of
arrogant white people smelly little
friend on a quest to ponder another
cultures sacred artifacts together
they'll unearth an ancient treasure
unleash an ancient curse and they won't
let you forget for a second how ancient
everything is instant persons ancient
burial site ancient Egyptian ancient
Arab stories of ancient booby-trap
ancient times ancient secret society
ancient Mary's ancient Egyptian trick
watch in horror as they accidentally
resurrect a motive an ancient Egyptian
priest who was so hated by the Pharaoh
he gave him superpowers for he would
arise a walking disease a plague upon
mankind and unholy flesh eater with the
strength of Ages power over the sands
and the glory of invincibility what
happened to murder his murder not work
anymore strap in for the 90s answer to
the Indiana Jones franchise that said
around the same time period in similar
locations and employs the same
combination of adventure comedy and
exact characters
Abner was sorry for dragging me all over
this earth looking for his little bits
of junk my father was a very famous
explorer there is nothing you can
possess which I cannot take away secret
of the Grail has been saved for a
thousand years
Brotherhood of the cruciform sword had
been prepared to do anything to keep it
since and for 3,000 years
we the Magi the descendants of Pharaohs
sacred bodyguards kept watch but in
fairness those indie movies were
inspired by classic adventure serials
which were inspired by radio dramas we
continued our journey along Solomon's
great road which were inspired by pulp
novels so let the mummy be yet another
reminder that nothing you've ever
enjoyed is original rescue the damsel in
distress kill the bad guy and save the
world so buckle up and write along as
our heroes track down a map that's
hidden behind a key which they need to
open some books look at the dead father
ancient foe tracks down some body parts
which he needs to find some jars for for
which he needs to bring back his lover
blood doesn't really matter though what
you're really here for is the charming
characters and the violins
the brutal dawn stop violins
Wow this movie is really violent
hey there's no blood so bring the kids
why are your eyes closed Billy there
aren't even any brains on the floor stop
crying or I'll make you watch the
Scorpion King
[Music]
starring Doom Patrol God of lore courage
that cowardly dude Darth Plagueis the
dry Court Russell aftereffects sand
texture a shadow with the face of
Stannis Baratheon and khakis 1001
Arabian whites since we know the mummy
is scared of cats why don't all the
heroes just a feed him by covering
themselves in cats hunt watch brendan
fraser in a cat suit to fit even more
Game of Thrones into your eyeballs click
the box to watch our after-show watching
Thrones or if you need to get caught up
before the game concludes check out our
Kremen of the complete series Show Me
The Mummy it's nerve of nothing I love
you 3000